now when it comes to brexit one of the
big things of course everyone's been
talking about is
what is the economic impact going to be
well no one really knows for sure but
it's worth just looking
at a few potential forecasts uh one
scenario that's been provided by the
office budget responsibility
uh kind of shows you pretty clearly uh
what they think might well happen
this line here shows you what could
potentially happen to gdp the best
measure of
economic growth if we stayed inside the
eu the fact that it's flat don't don't
read too much into that they are still
expecting growth but this is just so we
can compare these different potential
paths now
we're around here at the moment and this
is what their computer said as it were
for a free trade deal so down by about
four percent by the 2030s
and this is their no deal brexit
forecast and the key thing here to note
here
is the big gap isn't between these two
things the wto brexit no deal brexit and
the free trade deal is actually
between both of those and staying inside
the eu
and they think actually we've already
lost about 1.8 1.5 percent or so
uh of potential growth uh from uk gdp
but it's not just gdp it's also worth
you know looking at what businesses are
thinking
looking at the concerns that they have
for their balance sheets and this
surveys from the bank of england uh just
not long ago showing you
what various businesses said that would
be the potential impact
of brexit you can see there is a certain
chunk saying there's gonna be a large
negative or a small negative effect
uh over about kind of 30 percent or so
but the majority think there will be no
impact on their balance sheets enough a
few who think there could be a small
positive or a large positive
effect for their businesses so so more
balanced perhaps than you might have
made out
from some of the forecasting that we've
seen elsewhere and uncertainty has been
the key thing hanging over
these talks as they've gone on uh at
least some of that might have been
dispelled by now at least there's more
certainty
but you can see that uncertainty
starting uh quite high around 40
and then going up to around 60 percent
that's six percent of all businesses
saying
brexit is in the top three of their
concerns by 2019 and then into 2020
uh as well now one of the issues that's
hung over
the brexit talks and you know we've
talked about it uh an awful lot recently
is the uk's reliance on food imports so
this chart's basically going to show you
where we get our food from and it goes
all the way back
to 1988 you can see those are the
exports coming out of the
uk going elsewhere around the world
that's domestic production so anything
uh in the positive territory around kind
of you know 50 60 percent comes
from domestic sources and then you've
got the eu
the biggest contributor of uk food when
it comes to our imports
and then you can see africa the americas
and asia and others as well but just
know how big the eu's part
is in that and that's not going to
change our reliance on europe
as a source for our food and indeed
other goods
as well finally we've talked so much
haven't we recently about fishing the
fishing sector
uh has been in some ways one of the key
sticking points when it comes to these
talks
so it's worth just asking the question
here how big is fishing actually when
you take the uk economy and what i've
got here
don't try and read all of this small
print but this is basically every sector
in the uk economy from the biggest
services sectors down to
mining of coal and lignite down there at
the bottom now you might have asked
yourself you might have thought that
fishing
might be somewhere in the middle
somewhere near the top but actually have
a look at this
it's over there it is one of the
smallest parts
of the uk economy accounting for 0.018
of gdp but there we are that was one of
the key sticking
points in these talks and brexit well
that's some of the impact but it's gonna
take quite some time
before we know what is actually gonna
happen